muß wieso bringt euch jetzt sogar tasche
doch jetzt putze ich mir hier in der
folge die nase hey leute und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu minecraft hero
immer noch alleine und ich werde mich
immer noch in meinem haus ein bisschen
kümmern
ich hab mir gerade noch hier oft ein
bisschen kommentare durchgelesen aber in
allen ich soll mit ihren big sword
machen dass ein remix wort jetzt besser
ist als meine diamondbacks wort rx js
wirklich so viel besser ist ist wirklich
so viel besser ich mache jetzt einfach
mal runter man einiges soll eine andere
rüstungsteile bereit und aber kempf ist
direkt neben mir da kann die sich
einfach holen wenn wir aber immer
zusammen aufnehmen auch ich habe ja da
noch welche
darauf habe ich dann meine sachen so da
setzte den crafting table nicht einfach
für mich da gelassen
ich hasse das wenn sich einmal
verkraftet komme ich gar nicht mehr klar
und nochmal diamanten
12 ich mache jetzt einfach mal so im bix
bodyguard ob das so unglücklich gut ist
beim export oder das andere so ich muss
jetzt mal ganz kurz neben dem tier
ausprobieren das sind nicht furtado und
crack oder sonders vortag ich weiß nicht
aber dass das e 08 das ist nur in
wolfsburg ist es mittlerweile nur noch
nur weil wir halt so viele andere haben
naja das ist doch gar keine tierchen gut
ich will das jetzt nicht
foto ich wette furtado dings werden
jetzt von ihnen getötet
da sind gelbes yellow dog bo larsen
toubro das können wir aber ganz kurz
testen - 14 und brennend ja das ist
nicht besser
das wort nur - 10 was lagern die ich hab
das übrigens auch noch verzaubert
deswegen ganz außer dass es besser ist
aber hey hey hauptsache das album export
soll besser sein ja genau luca macht
einfach eine betriebswohnung
verschwendet weil ihr mann im kühler
dann einen arm ostend erstmal die leute
erstmal an bord stand dann wird sich
jeder lieber beschwert und den hier
ihren ich wollte mir vier machen hatte
vier mal so packe ich wollte ja es passt
sogar ohne dass irgendwo was hier
verbessern musste mit dem kästchen und
zwar glaube ich ich ich kenne jetzt
einfach die kräftig telefon da ich meine
wohl keiner können appelliert 2
das auf jährlich gut ich mag einfach da
rein
so ziemlich 24 davon
ich wollte dass eventuell so machen im
moment mal ganz guter test
gut kann man trotzdem öffnen ich wollte
da nämlich irgendwie so rein packen die
kisten der segen
was erstmal total doof dass ich die hier
unten gelegt habe obwohl hier einer muss
ja dahin damit ich hier so ca so kommt
wieder weg da kommen nämlich seine
kisten runter zu den drogen nimmt
da die schweben ja dann quasi scheiße
man wie schwer mir sehr gut
jetzt einfach mal so ich mir das zu
anfang gedacht hätte also da kommt an
die wand dazu ändert sind die
stützpfeiler sind hier zwei da kommt ein
stützpfeiler meisten verstehen grad
wahrscheinlich gar nicht was ich mache
aber in ca 3 4 folgen
außerdem live stream wieder unnötig
getötet aber egal das ist eine andere
sache
das plus wurde aus diesem anderen kram
hier machen dass ist berufspolitik
wahrscheinlich cool aus nikolaus marx
war mehr so wenn das dann so auf andere
holz farben trifft aber naja ich sollte
vielleicht erstmal dividende macht ja
wie mache ich dir in dem die wände hier
wie wir das machen das ein bisschen mit
coupies da machen wir alle mitkommen
stone
obwohl ich weiß nicht kommen es dann
oder dieses weißliche weiß nicht
wirklich weiter
könnte ja noch diensten
das kann ich eigentlich so lassen dass
das überhaupt die von der höhe
ja das passt alles doch wieder blöd aus
wenn das dann aber kommen die kisten vor
wurde ist es relativ egal ob mister
bescheiden eine wand oder irgendwie ein
fenster aber ähnlich weil da stehen ja
eh die kisten wie gesagt cool wäre es
wenn ich da die kisten hätte und an
daten fans doch irgendwie sowas weil da
oben können wir nicht nochmal kisten
sein
das soll er dann das dach darstellen
aber da mache ich da die seite einfach
komplett zu macht dann von außen liegen
die bilder oder irgendwie sowas keine
ahnung was die leute da wollen
so macht man hier noch ein bisschen mehr
bei mir bescheid
dabei schneit freunde so das sieht schon
doof aufriss ich mache jetzt einfach mal
es gibt noch durchaus nah sieht doppelt
lob aus dem stück bereits bei euch das
jahr killer luca haushalt mit links ab
wie kann ich das denn schön design die
aus acht kommen die auswahl ist jetzt
erst mal relativ egal da fällt mir schon
noch irgendwas an
wer kann ich auch jeder noch blumentöpfe
draufstellen obwohl ich das nicht auf
die höhe sondern windows wird es muss ja
quasi auf der wir bleiben weil da wollte
ich ja auch noch eine reihe hin machen
nein
nicht da so was kann ich hier zwischen
machen schreibt mir meine kommentare was
sollte ich da so zwischen bauen was kann
ich da so schöne zwischen machen
hier können ja fans da hinkommen aber
weil da hinten kommen ja keine fenster
zwischen weil er die kisten stehen
ich dachte ja doch ich dachte schon dass
pasta wieder nicht eben blieb aber es
passt doch ist mir dann aufgeführt
es passt eben wie alles erstaunlich gut
das hätte ich nicht gedacht am anfang
als ich das ich angefangen mit dem haus
holt sich das angefangen mit dem haus da
hätte ich nicht gedacht dass wir so gut
vorankommen
ich brauche viel höheren dienst antreten
dessen wird es eng wird wie einige tolle
zuschauer wissen ich habe probleme mit
eichen und birken
das sieht auch geld aus ist weil es doch
dass es irgendwo auf rewitz cacau sieht
zuläuft aber naja so ich wäre jetzt
einfach die klicken hier die hier so rum
stehen
wir müssen noch mal irgendwann auf
mexiko gegeben
ich werde jetzt im live stream nicht
mehr so sache machen wie ja ich mache
dann oder sowas sondern dann
wahrscheinlich nur sachen wieder einmal
eine existenz zu suchen da ein bisschen
auf kommentare eingehen dann hier in
essens farce machen damit auf kommentare
ein geht so was halt und nicht so
megamäßig kampf technisch blabla weil
das hat jeder glück gegen debitor so das
sollte eigentlich reichen
das sollte reichen ich reite einfach mal
auf ski zurück
ich war voll die trockene lippen
informierten künstlich eigentlich immer
wieder kommt er sogar oder killer so ich
parke jetzt erstmal hier draußen
bekommst du noch ich könnte hier für
tokio stark machen oder so dazwischen so
dass es dann zwar nur drei breit aber
das sollte eigentlich das reichte für
kinky brauch mehr
wir sind schwer werden minuten so ganz
viele hier von 53
dann kommen nämlich hier dran und dann
hier
so dass es schon mal die grobe
einkesselung so dann frage ich mich
etwas kann ich lade zwischen packen soll
ich das einfach nicht einfach vielleicht
einfach diese höhe
ich kann kein trottel was den vertrag
als ob ich jetzt keine platten
drauflegen kann nur da oben
wie soll ich das denn sonst jetzt machen
wir das war so geil aus mit diesem
halben dingsbums tag wie soll ich das
denn sonst machen
ich glaube schon gedient
so muss ich ja mehr oder weniger so
machen jetzt auch nicht so schlimm aber
ich finds halt irgendwie anders cooler
dass ich so 15 15
ja irgendwie viel ich das so nicht so
schön aber egal dann habe ich auf jeden
fall einen schönen platz für die fackeln
können dann hier schön unsere ich weiß
ich werde irgendwann ein schild brauchen
deswegen nehme ich das jetzt einfach mal
mittag muss wir so dringend sogar ein
taschentuch jetzt putze ich mir hier in
der folge die nase
so also wie mach ich denn jetzt hier
weiter auf jeden fall ich könnte ja
schonmal glas braten habe ich glas habe
ich glaub ich hab sogar noch ein glas
wie kann es sein dass ich noch ein glas
hab ich habe tatsächlich noch ein glas
nicht mehr ganz so da kann ich ja schon
mal sein dass ich kann doch nicht sein
dass ich noch ein glas habe 29 sind auf
jeden fall wo ich schon mal richtig
gedacht die kohle bleibt man so sand
kohle und zwar halt ja wir solchen
dingen könnte der komponist glas wein
ich finde die türen und ich finde mein
haus von vorne an sich relativ geil
ja ich find's cool so jetzt kommt von
ihr erst mal die erste selbst gepackt
dass auf jeden fall auch mega klug von
mir gewesen
oder sie sogar noch geiler sprit cadiz
bisschen zu dunkel aber wohl für
für die halterungen eventuell kann ich
ja mal
israel soll spaß nur witzig und sieht
besser aus wenn es in einer farbe hatte
ich glaube dass die besser sein dass in
einer farbe ist wir wollen jetzt auch
nicht so trotzdem vor die ganzen anderen
mitspieler neben unseren tausend farben
minimal geben so andere leute könnten
theoretisch sogar drei kisten herr ein
quatsch jetzt erst mal relativ egal ich
nehme es erstmal die kisten warte das
hier waren die wertvollen wertvoll nach
links wie wertvoll in die mitte mai
nicht braucht so viel mehr von dem
blöden ding so unglaublich so stöcker da
kurz auch 16 hin
dann habe ich nach 16 teile rumliegen
ach wir unnötig bin jetzt einfach mal
was ist da drin da war gar die framerate
christel bombay danke hier brudy seine
kiste gepackt mensch da das ja gar so
dass nämlich mal raus so so so so so so
dass man hier die wertvolle kiste die
sortiere ich mich auch noch ja wie
gesagt leute ich bin halt echt echt
krank dann will ich sagen kommt links
sondern die links kommt der kommt
manchmal tatsächlich kann ein schildchen
schreiben nach halle
oder er ist ja relativ egal du kommst
ist dahin
hey ich hab noch 15 kisten wieso und
dort aber ich würde es ist natürlich
einfach so alle gemacht oder das sieht
ja scheiße aus ja wie gesagt
da drauf
ja ich glaube das ist cooler wenn ich
das so machen
sorry dass ich jetzt hier wieder so ein
bisschen streife ich muss mal wieder
ganz viele hiervon machen sie ihren sind
jetzt jetzt mal eben einen vor
das blöde ist dass ich mir jetzt echt
1000 von diesem test transporter machen
muss weil ich die gleich wieder alle
umstellen muss egal leute so ist haus
ohne das ist hausbau jungs so und zwar
werde ich den ganzen handlungen sind
sogar langsamer das ist so heftig dieser
bleiben verzaubern
okay man trägt doch die ganzen sachen in
der kiste sind von daher ist er auch
relativ heftig beschädigt aber elf
minuten das ist so krass was ich machen
wollte war das hier ich packte hierhin
und dann stehen die kisten quasi so da
drauf ich hab keine mehr
helaba dass noch einer übrig geblieben
die kisten da drauf doch es brauche ich
reicht das drei reichen hallo da sag ich
mal noch mehr jungs aber stand noch ein
bisschen holz was nicht brauche redwood
des pik holzbau egal es ist zwar
eigentlich glaube ich sogar relativ
selten sticks auch müller
da habe ich einfach umsonst pink sticks
gemacht ich freue mich dass man andere
kiste obwohl das kult dem motto big six
core seien sie was wir sticks mache sind
diese blöden teile zum kisten
verschieben
dann nehme gott das ist ja egal da
müsste es darum auf dem forum
geschrieben und es darum auch noch mal
runter die da oben auch noch mal klappen
dann kommen die nämlich warte dahin
so und ich habe jetzt nur noch als
burger king ist doch alle nur spaß
zugang
jetzt muss das dach halt nur einen
halben höher und weiß jetzt gar nicht
wie ich das machen soll
wir sind schwächer bei 16 minuten das
ist das einzige was bisher geschafft hat
diese blöden würde kisten wand hierzu
schiff fertig zu stellen sondern kommen
nämlich die schilder daran was da
jeweils sonne ist dort unnötig laufen
kann ja nie mehr weil ich auch nichts zu
essen mehr hat bloß ich bin ins essen
zieht das löwen da sie zwei war das gut
sich einfach mal zu denen das ist die
erfolge wie mache ich das erstmal hier
ist ja noch mein glas ein bisschen wird
ich glaube ich ein bisschen ist da schon
fertig geworden so 64 haben bei jungs
gibt es reicht wenn ich wollte hier
schon eine glaswand kümmern
dann kommt man brauche ich das feld ein
bisschen um das kommt ja noch alles so
mache ich das jetzt einfach mal dann
nehme ich jetzt die red wings und plant
jetzt hier daran wird das für den da
vorne passt nur hier kommen zeitfenster
allen nur was genau die fenster zu
bringen in dem haus wo ich dann einfach
nur gegen ein anderes haus gucke da
nicht das andere aus wahrscheinlich
abfällen weil er es eh keiner drin ist
dann relativ macht was er dann relativ
egal
obwohl hell wenn ihr wirklich gefährlich
weil die fenster wirklich bleiben dass
ich erst mal eine art raumeinteilung
machen weil das soll nicht ein großer
raum werden das soll das soll noch ein
kleiner schlafraum rhein her muss ich
gucken oder ich mache hier sogar noch so
ein raum erhält das wär's wer das geil
wenn ich da noch so einen raum rein
machen würde wie ich das feiern dann
wird er dann irgendwie hier dann so
lange gehen war mal hier kommt ja es
kommt denn hier hin deutlich da könnte
ich ja eigentlich noch mal hab ich noch
ich hab noch
dann kommt da einfach das gleis ja das
kann ich zu lassen dann kommt dass sie
halt auch das ist halt dann für hier
besser hallo
auch manu 18 ich will das weiterbauen
ich will aber eigentlich nicht so viel
allein immer aufnehmen ich weiß nicht
wie er das findet wenn ich an einer
aufnehmen
so kenne ich ja das glas oder kann auf
jeden fall des sfb fax ein anderes mal
da muss dementsprechend hier auch wieder
so ein komischer gut kacke dings musste
auch gail
mit
kruska kruska kurth ich immer noch ein
bisschen auch man ich möchte so gerne
alleine weiter aufnehmen weil wir nur
noch 40 sekunden fällt es da ein paar
bäume und dann laufe ich wieder zurück
zu mir bzw
ich glaube ich nehmen sogar einfach so
durch auf ich glaube ich mal neutral das
war blöd gleich mal eine folge alleine
irgendwie ich weiß nicht mehr gefällt
das wenn ich alleine bin bin ich immer
richtig produktiv ich habe zwar nicht so
tolle themen immer so eine stimme aber
irgendwie markt auf ich finde dass ich
mal ich freue mich so meine lieben
freunde dann würde ich sagen
in solch gefallen hat und ihr mehr von
solchen alleinigen folge sehen wollt
kommt die nächste dann noch eine gibt
den daumen hoch zeigt mit einer
bewertung entweder halt daumen hoch oder
daumen runter und das war es